d'ailleurs on a un ça va oui bon ça a
pas l'air tue boîte non
chez les fissures anales ah ouais ça
fait mal ça non ça va son tout petit
j'aime pas trop bas pourquoi tu bois tu
alors j'ai j'ai mis des indices pour les
soigner famille des endives donc oui
j'ai vu ça sur instagram
je mets ça sur un stage d d d
endiguement salade quand même ah non non
entière c'est important et oui bien sûr
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ya pas très longtemps je suis tombé sur
un article qui décrivait le cas d'un
américain d'une trentaine d'années qui a
dû aller à l'hôpital pour se faire
retirer les six haricots rouges qui
s'étaient introduits dans l'urètre et du
coup je me suis dit que ce serait
peut-être pas mal qu'on discute un peu
tous ensemble des choses qui se font et
qui se font pas en matière de santé
alors attention deux petites précisions
avant de commencer d'abord aucun
jugement moral bien sûr chacun sait kink
et ensuite on va pas parler des remèdes
de grand mère savait genre mettre un
oignon ou une pomme de terre dans sa
chaussette avant de dormir pour soigner
un rhume ou faire baisser sa fièvre on
va pas non plus par les deux médecines
dites alternatives ou de médecine
traditionnelle ancestrale non là on va
plutôt parler de quelques initiatives
individuelles que des personnes emprise
soit pour améliorer leur santé soit pour
améliorer leurs performances sexuelles
et vous alors que de toute façon dans
les deux cas ça tourne pas mal autour de
la sphère génitale
des initiatives individuelles donc mais
vous allez voir que par la magie des
réseaux sociaux certaines ont fini par
faire leur petit bonhomme de chemin
alors dans l'absolu chacun fait ce qu'il
veut encore une fois mais il ya quand
même deux ou trois trucs que j'aimerais
vous rappeler si ça peut vous éviter de
finir aux urgences
vous avez donc revenons-en à notre
apprenti jardinier alors que le commun
des mortels se contente de faire germer
des lentilles dans du coton humide ce
brave homme a donc décidé de
s'introduire une demi-douzaine de
haricots rouges dans l'urètre lurette
qui je le rappelle pour ceux qui n'ont
pas suivi en svt n'est autre que le trou
du pic alors généralement les gens qui
s'introduisent des objets à cet endroit
c'est soit une forme d'auto mutilation
et là ça mérite qu'on en parle avec un
psy soit un jeu sexuel et j'ai déjà dit
on juge pas toi des gens qui veulent
passer du che l'icône carnet en
contrebande à la douane et qui s'y
prennent quatre indiens
en l'occurrence l'homme a expliqué qu'il
avait voulu voir si le fait de mettre
des légumes secs dans son pénis pouvait
lui procurer un plaisir plus intense au
moment de l'orgasme question qui
demeurait là sans réponse puisqu'il a
terminé aux urgences urologique puis au
bloc opératoire pour ce faire évacuer sa
petite salade mexicaine sous endoscopie
oui il en manque un je ne sais pas si
c'est le premier qu'ils ont réussi à
retirer manuellement ou le dernier
qu'ils ont trouvé dans sa vie alors en
l'occurrence se mettre des haricots secs
dans l'urètre ça n'est pas devenue une
traîne tik tok mais le cas a été repris
dans une revue médicale spécialisée en
urologie et l'article mentionne d'autres
cas similaires donc petite info santé
il est fortement déconseillé de
s'introduire des haricots rouges ou
toutes autres sortes de légumineuses
dans l'urètre
alors déjà je le rappelle les haricots
secs c'est des plantes grimpantes
mais le risque de ce genre de pratique
c'est surtout l'infection un corps
étranger qui reste en classe comme ça
dans l'organisme ça attire les germes et
là avec la v6 juste à côté paf
infections urinaires ça peut remonter
jusqu'aux reins et ça peut même
carrément finir en choc septique oui le
choc septique c'est quand une infection
est suffisamment importante pour finir
par avoir des répercussions sur la
circulation sanguine
la tension artérielle lbs et du coup les
organes sont pas irriguées correctement
au bout du compte le risque c'est de
décéder carrément sauf si ce qu'on s'est
mis dans le tuyau ça le bush
complètement là dans ce cas là on sera
obligé d'agir avant d'en arriver là
parce qu'on fera une rétention urinaire
chez orbit pis si le trou du pipi
déboucher le pipi n'y passe plus et ça
ça pique
s'applique et c'est dangereux parce que
quand la vessie elle est trop plein ses
parois est se distendent elle se
distendent et ça finit par abîmer les
nerfs les muscles les sphincters et c
est ça peut laisser des séquelles ça
peut même encore une fois aller jusqu'à
toucher les reins et ça c'est embêtant
et je vous parle même pas de la rupture
de la vessie
autre pratique peu conventionnel et pas
remboursés par la sécu se mettre des
pommes de terre dans l'anus pour soigner
ses hémorroïdes vous y avez peut-être
pas pensez vous comme ça spontanément
mais il ya suffisamment de gens qui
l'ont fait pour que des médecins
déconseillent officiellement d'avoir
recours à se remettre tout ça parce
qu'un certain nombre de sites avait
conseillé la recette sur
laver une pomme de terre et pelé la
scrupuleusement taille est là en
bâtonnets d'une taille à votre
convenance là c'est les bâtonnets au
congélateur insérez un bâtonnet dans
votre rectum pendant 30 secondes et
recommencez l'opération pendant trois à
cinq jours impeccable
alors pourquoi ça n'est pas une bonne
idée eh bien d'abord parce que ça ne va
pas soigner vos hémorroïdes je vous
renvoie à la vidéo que j'ai fait sur le
sujet le lien est dans la description ça
c'est le premier problème quand on a
recours à des trucs farfelues pour
régler un vrai problème de santé ça
soigne pas donc ça s'aggrave et pour
rester dans le cas précis qui nous
intéresse les hémorroïdes c'est fragile
donc aller les titiller avec un
truculent et dure pas une bonne idée
dans une moindre mesure ce qui tapissent
le canal anal et le rectum c'est de la
muqueuse d'ailleurs c'est une espèce de
membrane qui tapisse à peu près tous nos
orifices qui est comme une sorte de
petite peau très fine et très fragile à
les coller un truc congelés là dessus ça
risque de l'abîmer
ou pire et puis dernière chose le risque
quand on introduit dans son anus quelque
chose qui n'est pas idéalement profilés
et notamment qui ne comporte pas de
dispositif pour pouvoir l'extraire
facilement passer de ne pas pouvoir
l'extraire facilement justement ça
s'appelle des corps étrangers du rectum
on en a déjà parlé ici et là le risque
c'est pas tellement l'infection parce
que l'endroit est déjà plein de gerbes
dans le risque c'est que le tuyau se
bouche là encore et quand ce tuyau là et
bouche et on s'expose à des soucis qui
vont de la simple constipation jusqu'à
l'occlusion intestinale voire au pire du
pire au vomissement et calories c'est
bouché par le bas donc ça sort par le
haut
on avait déjà parlé je vous remets la
description si vous n'êtes pas à table
bref en un mot comme en cent
n'introduisait dans votre anus que ce
que vous êtes certain de pouvoir retirer
facilement
et pour soigner vos hémorroïdes
remettent ça c'est mieux qu'une frite
surgelée alors tant qu'on en ait dans la
rubrique cuisine et organes génitaux le
persil dans le vagin mauvaise idée si
cette manie que vous avez de vouloir
vous insérez des aliments dans les
orifices naturels vous avez pas de frigo
ou quoi une nouvelle fois vous allez
sûrement me demander d'où ça sort ce
truc et je vais vous répondre ça sort du
vagin en l'occurrence
aussi hilarant mais surtout c'est
vraiment un truc qui a été suffisamment
pratiquée pour que des médecins
britanniques attire l'attention sur le
fait que donc on ne fait pas ça et c'est
un magazine français qui avaient publié
un article sur les vertus emmène à gog
du persil emmène à gogh se veut pas dire
qu'on accompagne quelqu'un entre les
deux ça veut dire qu'ils régulent les
menstruations donc les médecins ont été
obligés d'expliquer par voie de presse
que la preuve scientifique de
l'efficacité de la chose et pas du tout
été fait mais qu'en revanche c'était
super dangereux on parle encore
d'infection comme tout à l'heure avec le
risque de chocs septiques nous on n'est
donc pas de persil dans le vagin pas de
yaourt pour équilibrer la flore et pas
de douches vaginales ou vinaigre de
cidre
[Applaudissements]
ou jure j'invente rien ça existe
vraiment on peut chercher pour toutes
les personnes qui possèdent un vagin
je veux pas match plein et c'est pas moi
qui le dit c'est les spécialistes plus
on le laisse tranquille plus il est
heureux de l'âge dans un cadre sanitaire
je veux dire sinon ça peut être inverse
mais c'est pas ce sujet donc en gros les
lingettes intimes les douches les
lavements les vapeurs vaginale et cetera
ça fait plus de mal que de bien à la
flotte le maj 1 il a une fonction auto
nettoyantes et il évacue tout ça dans
les sécrétions donc ce qui est conseillé
par les spécialistes c'est de nettoyer
la vulve avec un savon doux classique et
de laisser le vagin s'occuper de
l'intérieur globalement c'est valable
pour tous nos autres orifices on les
laisse se débrouiller sauf la bouche la
bouche c'est pas vraiment un orifice
donc vous pouvez y aller
s'il vous plaît pour clôturer le
chapitre culinaire le vinaigre de cidre
décidément ça ne fait pas agrandir le
pénis non plus spoiler rien ne fait
grandir le pénis donc fait avec ce que
vous avez c'est à dire pas juste un
pénis allez un petit dernier avant de se
quitter ses plus anciens pour le coup
vous en avez sûrement déjà entendu
parler le périnée hommes suning alors
bon on sait plus trop la saison mais vu
qu'on en reparle tous les étés et au cas
où vous auriez des petites vacances au
soleil prévue bientôt le périnée hommes
suning c'est ni plus ni moins que se
faire bronzer l'anus enfin
exposé son anus au soleil pour le coup
c'est quelque chose qui a été relayée
par de nombreuses personnes sur
instagram des influenceurs trou de balle
sans doute mais attention c'est pas à
visée esthétique ni n'essaie pas de se
faire griller la crème pour l'avoir bien
dorées non l'idée c'est de faire le
plein d'énergie
d'après les apôtres du beau soleil à na
li
6 mois
mais alors quelle énergie pour faire
entrer par là une instagram du nom de
métaphysique hall mégane explique que je
la cite
le soleil émet une pure lumière plasma
plein d'informations et de codes
lumineux qui aident le corps humain dans
la transformation et l'activation de
notre adn dormant je ne sais même pas
quoi vous dire à part que évidemment là
encore les médecins disent que ça ne
repose sur absolument rien de
scientifique évidemment et puis aussi
deux choses premièrement si vraiment
c'est un truc qui est destiné à être
exposé au soleil
pourquoi notre anus et orienté vers le
bas est planqué entre de fès
et deuxièmement on parle encore de
muqueuses là c'est hyper fragile même si
c'est juste trente secondes c'est pas
une bonne idée d'exposer sa au soleil
surtout que bon si c'est tous les jours
au bout d'un moment dans le doute
bref je laisse le mot de la fin à une
vers matt au log system globalement
avant de suivre un conseil santé que
vous avez trouvé sur les réseaux sociaux
qu'on vous a donné à la terrasse d'un
bar ou n'importe où renseignez vous
auprès de quelqu'un dont c'est le métier
on aurait pu aussi parler de cette
personne qui s'est injecté son propre
sperme dans les veines pour soulager un
mal de dos ou de cet autre qui
s'injectaient du ciment dans les fesses
pour les raffermir on aurait pu parler
des gens qui boivent leur urine on
aurait pu parler de plein d'autres trucs
encore et peut-être qu'on le fera dans
une autre vidéo mais retenez déjà ces
quelques petits conseils que je viens de
vous donner sur ces petits trucs santé à
éviter si vous voulez effectivement
rester en bonne santé voilà détester
c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos d'ici là prenez soin de vous et
prenez soin des autres mettez vous bien
et surtout portée
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]